it's interesting that um there are 30
million manufacturing jobs uh that need
to be filled and that can't be filled by
2025 and in high-tech sectors like
semiconductors there are
300,000 uh vacancies uh this year this
shows you that the present problem is
not that you know there are not enough
jobs but there there's big gap in terms
of education and skill now these Chinese
students very smart and very very
educate very well educated and
impressive however they don't have
internships many of them don't have um
don't show the kind of business Acumen
and flexibility mental flexibility
because they have been overburdened by
uh a competitive test taking rot
memorization kind of education system so
they're not that appealing to the
private businesses that demand passion
interests ethics and some experience so
so I think that there are lots of things
to fix and they will be a positive force
for the new generation but the whole
economy has to change somewhat yeah but
there's an interesting again anecdote in
the book where you say that there was a
a a cigarette making plant where the the
people assembling the cigarettes were
all graduates and some of them
post-graduates on that line top Masters
and college students uh in cigarette
factories nannies uh that have Master
degrees from Colombia uh these are all
things that have caused uh a social
uproar you got to ask you know the
Chinese families what what what what is
it all about their their hope right it's
all about the Next Generation for a long
period of time the bottom run of society
was uh happy and content because they
knew that their children could have a
better future that's what sustained that
was the Bedrock to social stability
today it's a completely different issue
with reduced expectations that even if
you poor and about 25% of household uh
expenditure are devoted to educating one
child if you are investing that much
resources in the end your kid doesn't
get a good job then what what is your
hope what are you what are you how are
you going to look into the future and
the kid itself must feel horribly
demoralized because all the family's
hopes are poured into them and then
perhaps through no fault of your own you
haven't delivered there's a new
phenomenon called lying flat uh
basically giving up uh now that's become
a focal point for the Chinese leaders uh
they don't think that this is something
that should be encouraged um but you
know I want to take a different
perspective on this lying flat is not
about being utterly disgruntled and
giving up per se it's also uh come to
characterize a a part of the new
generation that is more relaxed that's
less ambitious that is less hungry now
don't forget that when China joined the
WTO one of the core reasons why 2001
that was in 2001 when it w when it was
so successful was not because of the
subsidies but because there was a large
swath of really productive and super
hardworking lab labor force where the
foxcon uh workers opted for three nights
three shifts a night that generation is
is gone that's not the current
generation of of new workers so we want
to think about China's new generation as
having a better lifestyle life
consumption balance and work uh work
life balance and have a different Vision
different perspective they're not going
to compete and race for the bottom and
that's that kind of job is going to be
passed on to other countries it's always
a cycle of renewal
what about the um kind of social
political implications of that because
as you say you cite in the book a few
kind of world valued surveys which
suggest that perhaps surprisingly to
many in the west Chinese people are
basically among the more contented in
the world I don't know you know what the
methodology of these things are but
let's take them at face value but if you
now have a rising generation who have
disappointed expectations that must be a
concern it's a concern to any government
but to a a one party state which which
relies on it legitimacy performance
legitimacy is a phrase the Chinese have
often quoted at me are they concerned
about
that they they are currently now very
focused on the new generation let's not
forget that the Young Generation were a
critical part of ending the pandemic
controls and so uh their credibility
their legitimacy rest on the the the the
trust of this new generation so there
are a variety of things that the Chinese
government is doing for instance
expanding the capacity and quality
vocational schools uh the the Gap in
manufacturing as I spoke about is
because China is primarily still a
manufacturing based economy so they want
to educate and equip these students the
new generation with the right skill set
to fill that Gap they are expanding the
service sector where many of these
Highly Educated people can be absorbed
more than uh manufacturing sectors so
and and even you know the common
Prosperity uh uh policies which includes
you know trying to um Crackdown in
technology and education sectors of
course it was unfortunately implemented
and had severe consequences on the
economy but by Design and intention they
were trying to make the society more
harmonious less competitive more this is
where where they said uh they almost
overnight said private tutoring illegal
is and that why why was that done
because they felt too much money and too
much pressure on people too much
pressure on the kids overburdened by
tutorials it's a race to the bottom
because everybody spends to have more
tutorials and that doesn't get you
anywhere just give me a picture of the
kind of social life that involved for
the the children involved what was going
on they have the busiest schedule uh of
everybody uh Saturdays and Sundays
packed with life classes a day and
tutorials even after classes uh during
the weekday even um people from the
working class are sending their kids to
tutorials uh you know really spending a
lot of money but to what effect in the
end it's all the same it's all just test
taking yeah and so overnight the
government said okay this is going to
stop uh there were also um you know
there were also exploitative uh
motivations of these private tutorial
companies so I think the intention is
not a wrong one but you be basically
killed a a part of the industry
overnight and this these kind of
dramatic moves we often find so uh so
radical in uh in in the Chinese
government sometimes they're first of
all meant to um make a loud you know
make a big Point um to signal and then
they're gradually roll back so it's a
it's a process of constant recalibration
and fine-tuning uh and the Pendulum
often swings but it's often very
dramatic in the beginning yeah but it
also tells you something about how
dramatically the Chinese government's
way of operation differs from say a
standard Western Government I can't
imagine the UK government saying
overnight okay no more private tutoring
that's it couldn't be done we the
Western governments have argued for a
long time about regulating big Tech
regul ating Ai and little is done uh
China for all what you disagree with
their implementation procedures tend to
can move quickly once they've made up
their mind so there's pros and cons of
both yeah just on this aging thing I
mean one of the great things that uh you
hear all the time is this this phrase
that China will get old before it gets
Rich that the uh inadvertently dcha ping
kind of put a a landmine under the
Chinese economy because dependency
ratios are going to go wild out of whack
you'll have shrinking population and
aging population and that this is what
in the end will slow the Chinese economy
down cause it big problems what's your
take on that I don't I don't agree with
this the The View that aging is what's
going to cause the Chinese economic
slowdown um as I mentioned I think uh
just deploying the most productive and
educated part of the labor force today
is a more pressing issue but also I tend
to believe that the economy is
endogenous that Technologies and Dem
Graphics interact with each other uh
that there will be more adoption of
Labor saving Technologies just as the
case in Japan and we're now talking
about uh artificial intelligence uh
displacing many jobs uh the question is
can you get the right kind of education
to deal with a modern economy can you
get the people who are present who are
educated to do F self fulfilling jobs
and here I think the government can play
a big role and by the way if you look at
the economic impact of demographics
across countries internationally
something I've done search on it doesn't
show up as a significant factor driving
uh uh major slowdowns in the economy PE
countries like Japan uh and other places
which have had aging issues there were
other really really pressing uh
macroeconomic factors that were more
dominant as driving force yeah well I
mean you mentioned the the deflation of
the Japan bubble and obviously those
parallels are in everyone's mind I think
well maybe you know China will be a bit
like Japan have this incredible Surge
and then suddenly slow and one well one
thing that sorry it's one thing that did
strike me as a parall property with that
there was a big property bubble in Japan
and there does seem to be one in China
as well you make the point that people
on salaries that are like maybe a
quarter of an American middle class
salary are paying similar prices for
Flats in Shanghai that would that they
would be paying for in Boston the
Japanese L decade was uh in large part
due to the collapse of a big asset
bubble we have not seen the collapse of
a big asset bubble in China not least at
least not yet uh even with the raining
in the property sector we've seen
investment slow down negative investment
growth but the prices have not Fallen
dramatically and the reason is multiple
fold but one is that there's still a
huge pent up demand for urban uh
properties if you think about the
Chinese rural population by the way 600
million of which have not even reached
middle income by International standards
they all want an apartment in urban
areas um it's a status symbol as I
mentioned in the book Bachelors want to
have a property to to to kind of
showcase that they are eligible um so
the penup demand is there there was an
over supply for a period of time because
property for uh for for for for all this
time was a cheap sorry a quick win uh
and that has uh just completely changed
but it's nowhere like Japan where there
was a big collapse and a break of the
bubble uh currently so I don't think
that China is going to suffer from a J
ja Japanese economic
decline